[Music]
hey what is up guys mphd here and this
is the iphone 6s now i know it might be
a little bit hard to tell the difference
between the 6 and the 6s at first glance
so this video is everything you need to
know that is new and different about the
iphone 6s first of all the design so on
the outside the design remains nearly
the same not identical but obviously
super familiar for iphone 6 users for
those of hot guys you'll notice the
iphone 6 has all the fcc markings on the
bottom and no s badge then the 6s came
out after you were no longer required to
have the fcc markings so they got rid of
them and it looks a little bit cleaner
though the s badge i guess looks a
little bit out of place anyway the main
way you'll actually be able to tell if
someone has the new iphone is if they
have the new pink color
you mean rose gold right
it's pink so
dude it's rose gold it's like a pale
faded version seriously it's rose gold
all right it's rose gold anyway the real
difference on the outside is that
apple's now using a 7000 series aluminum
which makes for a stronger body which
means it won't bend as easily it's even
reinforced internally around the volume
buttons where it bent last year you
can't see that but it's there overall
though button placement headphone jack
mute switch etc all the stuff is in the
same place it's still also the rounded
shape of last year and i've said this
before the rounded sides make it a bit
slippery in the hands so you already
know what to do although something to
note this new iphone is thicker taller
and wider than the iphone 6 so your
cases and skins from last year probably
won't fit depending on how precise they
are one of my favorite changes though on
the front of the new iphone is the new
touch id this new fingerprint sensor is
ridiculously fast some might even say
too fast it's fast to the point where if
you wake up your phone and unlock it
with your finger on the home button you
might actually miss the notifications
that you could have read on your lock
screen which is pretty funny because you
can basically unlock touch id with just
a tap now and not holding the home
button you can just touch it and it'll
read your fingerprint that fast the work
around of course to not being able to
read your notifications or just check
the time would be to use a different
finger to check that or resort back to
that trusty sleep wake button so the
next big upgrade with the iphone 6s is
on the inside the specs so when the 3gs
first came out apple said the s stood
for speed technically they haven't said
anything since then so i'm just going to
assume the s again stands for speed
because this phone is insanely fast it's
rocking apple's new a9 chip technically
a dual core chip but two very powerful
cores near two gigahertz and two
gigabytes of ram which is plenty for ios
as we know so multitasking is great it
keeps more apps in memory now longer
than they did before and overall
day-to-day performance is super snappy
frame rates are consistently high i've
been using this this phone for weeks so
it's not just a brand new phone being
fast apps open and close really quickly
and performance throughout is top notch
the 6s drops some insane scores too in
geekbench on par with some laptops so if
that gives you any idea this phone is
blazing now there is one spec that's
actually technically worse than it was
before and that's the battery on paper
you actually have technically a slightly
smaller battery in these new iphones
than you did in the previous so the
iphone 6s is down to 1715 milliamp hours
and the iphone 6s plus down to 27.50 the
battery life however is still about the
same meaning the iphone 6s battery is
okay it'll probably last you a full day
normally but heavy days you might find
yourself needing to plug in before the
end of the day but the iphone 6s plus
battery is really good that's one of the
benefits of a bigger phone the 6s plus
has one of the best battery life in any
smartphone it has awesome standby time
meaning you can forget to charge it at
night and not have any worries and i've
failed to kill it in a day so i'm more
than happy at the end of the day ending
with 20 to 30 battery life even after
normal or heavy use now the next main
thing that's changing the iphone 6s is
the display now the panel itself is
still the same it'll still look the same
a 1334 by 750 ips panel on the iphone 6s
and the 1080p lcd on the 6s plus but the
display now has some extra hardware to
make it pressure sensitive apple calls
it 3d touch and it's basically the
iphone's biggest new feature now it's
called 3d touch not force touch because
it has multiple layers of pressure
sensitivity and that's what allows for
what apple calls peak and pop nobody
actually calls it that but that's what
apple's naming it so in an app that
supports 3d touch if you see something
you like you can press into it with a
bit of pressure to peak to see what it
is and if you like what you see you can
press even harder to pop into that thing
to view it full screen and that's the
essence of peak and pop it's not just a
long press so you can actually peek into
something and then decide that's all you
want to see and then you can release it
to minimize it back you can also 3d
touch on the home screen so apps that
support it will reveal quick shortcuts
to functions inside them when you press
with some pressure and a couple of apple
apps support this to start a few
third-party ones are doing this too and
with a little practice you can kind of
get to remembering where certain
functions are in a shortcut so you can
actually get it to do what you want to
do a little bit quicker it works pretty
well now but we have to remember this is
still pretty early for the new iphones
and a lot of the apps that we use today
aren't supported by 3d touch developers
however are getting on that and when
developers build in 3d touch
functionality in a meaningful way into
their apps it'll start to build out and
it'll be a lot more prevalent throughout
the whole os so again right now when
it's early it seems a little bit
excessive like gimmicky but it'll become
very important in the future when an app
isn't supported and you try to 3d touch
the icon on the home screen for example
the new haptic engine gives you this
quick triple buzz and it blurs the edges
letting you know there's nothing to see
here so you kind of figure out which
apps have 3d touch functionality and
which don't in a matter of just going
around and pressing all the apps on your
home screen until you find the good ones
overall i think 3d touch is pretty cool
but again it will only get cooler in
time thanks to developers so the last
but not least new thing on the iphone 6s
is the camera the phone is rocking a new
12 megapixel sensor same flash and
mostly the same optics and everything
just a new sensor with the new specs to
back it up i have taken a lot of photos
with my iphone 6s plus partly because
you know i'm testing it and it's a new
camera but also because iphones
consistently like encourage taking
photos the camera interface has been
some of the best balances of control and
ease of use in any smartphone in my
opinion so i love the app and it's super
fast and responsive and easy to take a
great photo so iphone 6s plus also
benefits from having optical image
stabilization so low light photos are a
little bit cleaner and video looks a lot
smoother so here are the photos and
honestly you're not going to notice like
a whole ton of difference in detail
getting 12 megapixels versus 8 but most
of the improvements you're going to
notice i actually see in the colors and
the image processing not a whole lot of
sharpening going on but there's still
plenty of detail throughout the frames
and you'll probably notice colors are
kind of warm throughout like every scene
and that's actually pretty natural and a
good representation of the actual
subject as opposed to sort of cooling
off the colors which might look a little
better at first but is less accurate it
handles exposure great and dynamic range
is pretty good since hdr is never really
too aggressive since it's auto hdr and
same thing in low light you start to see
a little bit of noise as you would
expect but overall nothing too crazy
here and again this is pretty much all
just walk up to the subject point and
shoot now jumping from 8 megapixels to
12 now means the iphone finally has
enough pixels to shoot that 4k video i
love so much and the video from the
sensor is beautiful as expected now if
you're serious about shooting a lot of
video on the iphone you pretty much have
to go 6s plus to get that optical image
stabilization but yeah more of the same
characteristics show up here detail
without being overly sharp and great
exposure and dynamic range while not
blowing things out and accurate colors
with warm tones all the way through
there's also a new feature in the camera
this year called live photos and i've
tried really really hard to give this a
chance and see if it's not a gimmick but
it kind of is basically live photos
which are enabled by default captures
one and a half seconds before and one
and a half seconds after you press the
shutter button for every picture and you
can even see the live indicator while
you're capturing after you hit the
shutter button so you can sort of view
that short gif with sound by 3d touching
the photo you just took and seeing the
lead up to the shot and then what
happened right after it can be cool
every once in a while like being able to
see something blowing in the wind or
capturing the lead up to a photo or what
happened right after you click the
shutter i don't know my live photos
would probably be a little more
interesting if i was taking pictures of
more dynamic things like people but
instead most of mine are just picking
the camera up
and then putting the camera back down
usually back into my pocket so there's
an update coming to prevent this from
happening by having the iphone read the
accelerometer and gyroscope to know when
you stop holding your phone up but yeah
that's pretty much it for live photos
there's no way to share them you just
share the normal picture and all you
have to do with them is set them as your
wallpaper or make them your apple watch
face basically i've come to the
conclusion that live photos are just a
really big beautiful demo for 3d touch
and that's fine it's enabled by default
they take up the space of two photos
instead of one so not a big deal with
storage and the only way to view them is
with a 3d touch so learn it 3d touch is
going to be important really soon that's
it that's everything that's new with the
new iphone 6s uh it's running ios 9 and
if you're already using a previous
iphone you're probably already very
familiar with ios 9 so i don't need to
tell you about the slightly new font or
the slightly worse multi-sassing
carousel in my opinion
you're already familiar with the
experience if you're not coming from an
iphone you might be interested in the 6s
for its blazing fast performance and
ease of use an awesome camera my biggest
problem with it is
16 gigabytes really
uh with 4k video and live photos and
everything like that honestly it's 2015.
we're pretty much done with that 16 gig
phones need to die and it's not just
apple everyone stop it anyway that's
been it i guess let the hype train begin
for the iphone 7. uh thank you for
watching this review video if you
enjoyed it feel free to hit that like
button down below and if you have any
comments or questions i'll be hanging
out in the comments section below and we
can chat there as well thanks for
watching and i'll talk to you guys in
the next one
peace